also breaking overnight in Paris police
fired tear gas and arrested more than
200 people this morning a so-called
anti-government yellow vest protesters
took to the streets for a fourth
consecutive weekend the city is on high
alert
following the violence that broke out
last weekend we're seeing the closing of
the Eiffel Tower shops and museums
copycat protests are reported in Belgium
Charlie d'Agata is in Paris this morning
Charlie good morning good morning well
we watch throughout this morning as is
crowded maybe 200 people is now swollen
to several thousand stretching down the
length of the Schanz Alizee all the way
up to the Arc de Triomphe every now and
then a group of rowdy demonstrators will
try to burst out into the side streets
and avenues and they're met with a wall
of riot police when that happens we've
heard it ourselves rallies have been
firing back with stun grenades and tear
gas in order to disperse the crowd even
so this is relatively tame and contained
to what they had here last week where
demonstrations to send it into chaos and
destruction 400 people were arrested in
order to avoid that they pumped up a
number of security personnel to 89,000
in order to try to contain these crowds
not just here in Paris but elsewhere
throughout the country now this all
began when French President Emmanuel
macron introduced a fuel tax like
several weeks ago and the demonstrations
have just gotten bigger he has since
climbed down from that demand but now
this has gone too big they say it's too
little it's too late the people that
we've seen here today are calling for
the French president's resignation we're
expecting these crowds to bills and
perhaps get more violent throughout
today for CBS this morning Saturday
Charlie d'Agata Paris